Speaker 1: Let's get right into some
of vaccination related controversies,
more and more. The question is coming up, is it
time to fire unvaccinated employees or is it just
time to say, listen, all of this stuff about if
it's over a hundred employees, then you can test
weekly, although some places like Fox News
are even stricter and they're saying, well,
no, you've actually got to test daily.
Is it just time to end all of it? And I
want to look at a couple of articles with you.
Interesting article in Salon by Amanda Marcotte
called It's Time to Start Firing Unvaccinated
People. Trump fans are overdue for a lesson in
consequences. The absolute certainty of losing
a job is going to motivate a lot more people
than the more abstract risk of dying. For those
readers who only peruse headlines, the impending
first round of vaccine mandate deadlines are
looking like a very scary business. Not for
people who are afraid of needles, mind you, but
those who are afraid that mass resignations and
firings and subsequent staffing shortages,
shortages of essential workers are coming.
These health care workers would rather
get fired than get vaccinated, reads
a Monday morning headline at The New York Times.
New York Hospitals Face Possible Mass Firings As
Workers Spurn Vaccines is another headline.
Rural hospitals worry they will lose staff
because of Biden's new vaccine mandate, warns an
NPR headline. New York may use the National Guard
to replace unvaccinated health care workers. Now,
one part of this, which I'm going to talk about
in the next segment is whether a lot of these
people are lying about quitting, whether these
are empty threats. I believe that they mostly
are. And I'm going to give you data to support
that in the next segment. But the question here
is for the people who really are going to refuse,
is it just time to start firing them? As we talked
about yesterday on the bonus show, the state of
New York is the first test case of what actually
enforcing a government issued mandate looks like.
Monday's the deadline for health care workers
in New York to get the job or get the pink slip.
As The New York Times reports, resistance to
vaccine mandates has so far stopped most states
from threatening to fire unvaccinated workers. But
New York's newly appointed governor is calling the
unvaccinated bluff. Rather than caving in and
letting them keep their jobs, she is prepared
to call the National Guard to fill in the
shortages left by the upcoming fire firings. What
I believe needs to happen here is that we should
allow these folks to quit if they really are
willing to quit and most are not. And it should be
seriously considered by employers whether to just
fire people rather than to require the testing.
You know, half of unvaccinated workers in some
polls have said they'd rather quit than get the
vaccine. The real world data doesn't suggest
that that's actually the case and that most of
these folks are not actually going to quit now.
One important question would be, if the mandates
didn't work, would they make sense? Because at the
end of the day, what I care about is actually
getting people vaccinated. The article goes on
to say, The effectiveness of mandates has been
documented outside of New York, as well as Dr.
Zeke Emanuel, former White House policy adviser
who works for you. Pen now told fierce health
care, health care systems that have
actually mandated this have retained
over 99 percent of their workforce. That number
we find elsewhere as well. The article goes on to
list over a dozen hospital systems that have
implemented vaccine mandates. In every case,
the fraction of workers lost was tiny, certainly
well worth losing to protect patients and the
larger community from covid similar success
at United Airlines started putting workers on
leave. If they don't get vaccinated, 97 percent of
employees beat the deadline. And then the sort of.
Conclusion here is this is precisely why vaccine
mandates are so important, the absolute risk
of losing a job is going to motivate a lot more
people than the abstract risk of dying of covid.
But for the threat to become real, it has to be
real. And this means it's not enough to threaten
to fire people who won't get vaccinated. Employers
and governments have to follow through who is
right to do whatever it takes to make sure that
the unvaccinated get their pink slips. This week,
if leaders back down in the face of vaccine
resistance, the numbers will double down and
continue spreading covid in a pathetic effort
to own the liberals. Threats cannot be empty,
especially when facing stubborn people who
believe themselves impervious to consequences.
Threats need to be backed up with action.
It's time to start firing the unvaccinated.
I completely agree with this. And you, if you
want to make the case that a business shouldn't
even issue the threat or that these should not
be the battle lines on this issue, you can have
that debate. You could say. Actually, I think it's
counterproductive to mandate the vaccine. The data
says actually the vaccine mandates work very well,
97 to 99 percent when companies put it in place.
Most people aren't actually going to quit
their job. But once you've gone to doing it,
the threat can't be an empty threat because
otherwise it's not going to be effective. And
much like I mean, you know, this is kind of like
the strict father morality that the right often
preaches, which we on the left often say, you
know, we want to make sure it's well calibrated.
It can't be an empty threat. And what we are
finding is that even among those threatening
to quit about the vaccine, very, very few
actually are. Let's talk about that next